hello and welcome to this dw business
special i'm rob watts and this week
we're talking all about the future of
globalization the world economic forum
meeting in davos this year came with the
usual messages about working together to
solve the world's problems but this time
round it also came against the backdrop
of a fragmenting world the war in
ukraine has forced nations to pick sides
when it comes to trade often between the
west and the rest i.e those countries
unwilling to condemn russia for its
actions what's more concern over chinese
dominance has seen europe and the u.s
take up a less cooperative and more
competitive stance towards the asian
economic powerhouse
well to help us answer the question is
this the end of globalization i'm joined
firstly in the studio by dw's ben
fazoulin he's been our man at the world
economic forum annual meeting in davos
and you're fresh off the plane as well
from switzerland not all that fresh yeah
we almost thought you were going to make
it so we're very happy to have you with
us we're also joined on the line by
anahita toms from multinational law firm
baker mckenzie she's going to be able to
give us some insight into how world
trade is changing thanks a lot for
joining us anahita it's good to have you
now i'll come back to our guests in a
moment but first to explain talk of the
end of globalization comes after decades
in which the received wisdom has been
that international trade leads to a more
peaceful world well since the turn of
the millennium we've seen countries
cooperating on goods and services like
never before in the year 2000 just have
a look here global trade amounted to 6.4
trillion u.s dollars but last year it
was more than triple that at 19 trillion
dollars even the coronavirus pandemic
couldn't stop it hitting a record high
so i'm going to begin by asking ben
fazoulin here in the studio with me uh
you've been at davos what's the feeling
there is is globalization something that
they're talking about or deglobalization
perhaps more accurately this was a
completely different davos to
any other davos i've been to this was my
seventh or eighth and every year it's
about new partnerships trying to make
globalization work trying to make a more
global world despite all of the
criticism that you get that it's only
the wealthy who are who are benefiting
from it
in this case we've suddenly hit this
point where
everything's falling apart
people are running around trying to do
deals with this country in that country
um
and there was
an urgency to this uh davos because of
ukraine but also
uh almost a a panic behind the scenes
and i wouldn't say that we're seeing a
deglobalization but rather
a push towards a more sustainable
globalization so
de-risking
of supply chains i spoke to one investor
from zurich who said that
we're too lazy we're too cheap and we
don't learn
russia had turned off the taps before
as far as gas and ukraine go
but it doesn't take a war or a pandemic
all it takes is a ship getting stuck in
the sewers canal to show that the system
doesn't work yeah it's amazing that we
have had all of these things just in the
last couple of years is davos
traditionally is it fair to say in a
place where you're you're hearing pro
globalization
messages
yeah definitely i mean that's where
they've always said come on guys we've
got to work together we've got to make
this world a better place
but
that plan is not going to work anymore
because of the way china's going because
of what russia's done
and also the economic side of things
we've got to remember that
china is no longer going to be
giving us that stellar growth that the
world has relied on for so long and this
year we could see um
china
shrinking for the first time we could
see the us outpacing chinese growth for
the first time yeah we're going to talk
plenty more about china during this of
course and we'll also be talking great
deal about russia as well but i just
want to bring in anahita toms for the
first time thanks a lot for joining us
once again can you tell us whether you
think that we are heading for a world
actually where it's not so much about
free trade between nations but actually
where it's more restricted and more
selective
i would say that we are definitely more
selective and we have to work towards
diversification
but globalization is not a thing of the
past although the frontiers have changed
and we're talking about geopolitical
tensions but we have also seen a
pandemic climate change
and
a question about our values our common
values and because of these frontiers
changing we really need to invest more
into innovation we also need to invest
more in resilience in our supply chain
and this definitely includes
diversification as well but i think we
also need to have a very honest
discussion because there are some
products we cannot or do not want to do
without and
we can discuss about various products
for example cobalt in congo
and
replacing specific products are is
challenging
and i would say the following
because it was subject to
various discussions in the past few
months
it is important to keep in mind that
withdrawing from critical regions is not
always the solution
there are factories that would have to
be closed because
clearly there are
you know handled
under very bad conditions but our
responsibility is to help local
communities get better because what is
clear too that many people are dependent
on their incomes and if western
companies just leave that can have
major impacts on the local community
community so i would echo
that what we need to do is to work
towards a more sustainable trade
relationship
and that
includes having honest discussions
i think that also includes not just uh
companies because companies have been
you know working out that their
customers and their workers want to work
for a company or be involved with a
company that has values and has morals
but it's also governments you know
government's choices with whom they're
going to work and to trade deals this is
something i do want to talk a bit about
actually which is how much
government should be taking into account
the ethics of the the places in which
they want to invest and to trade i
actually want to just
hear a sound bite from someone from from
davos so the war in ukraine has
obviously brought about a massive shift
in global trade the west and its allies
have begun to isolate russia wherever it
isn't too self-destructive to do so so
just have a listen to director general
of nato jens stoltenberg speaking in
davos
trade has brought a lot of prosperity
and wealth to all of us
but the problem is that it has a price
because some of this trade some of this
economic interaction with authoritarian
regimes is undermining our security and
then we have to choose security
instead of
vulnerability and overreliance on
authoritarian regimes
so this idea that you know we should
free trade in natural gas meaning we can
buy as much gas from russia as you want
that's wrong
it's dangerous
yes ben is that a message that you were
hearing while you were there that you
need to be more selective or western
nations you need to be more selective
about who they trade with well more
multinationals we're already seeing this
pulling out of russia
we just had starbucks was the latest
more multinationals are pulling out of
china as well
there are reports that apple could be
which would be very interesting and uh
the west is likely to become a warrior
importer of chinese goods at the same
time china
is looking at becoming more self-reliant
and we've heard that time and again over
the the past years from xi jinping and
uh just this week as well
actually
you mentioned china because that is
something that we we do need to talk
about because europe is heavily reliant
on china for
all manner of technologies particularly
future technologies and those associated
with decarbonization just have a look
here when it comes to electric car
motors the eu imports 65
of its raw materials just look here
the country also accounts actually for
54
of turbine components and it's not just
in europe's clean energy sector where we
see domination from china there's a key
component of solar panels it's called a
polysilicon and over the past decade
china has increased its share of the
global market to achieve almost total
domination on that front um i just want
to bring in anahita toms again on this
one anahita
is
the idea of trying to change countries
through trading with the vandal door
candle that uh germany in particular has
sought to espouse over the years is that
is that something that's been shown to
have failed
i get this question all the time
to think that trade interest would lead
to an export and universal adoption of
the western democratic model
everywhere in the world
has always been a wide-eyed approach
if you look at the democracy index you
you are aware that
one third of the world's population
lives in dictatorships still
this being said to think that one has no
influence on a country
where you have entrenched trade is also
incorrect
i would say it is a nuanced analysis
that we need to have and and again an
honest discussion
although the expert of the democratic
model has not been effective in some
countries
economic relationships
have
influence and also influence on
political decision making but also
particularly on living conditions of
local communities
and
we also have to take into account the
positive examples if one regards nato
and the eu
historically these countries as you are
very well were often at war
and
through
interdependence and deep trade ties the
platform for dialogue continuous dialect
was created of course there are common
values here
but i think just because not everywhere
we were quote unquote successful i think
the underlying mechanisms of
international cooperation and also
through mechanisms like um
the wto we can
uh trigger change and
i think also when you look at
how
how quickly can things actually change i
think it is also an investment in time
and
i just want to reiterate just because in
a few cases it didn't work it doesn't
mean
that
through trade we cannot positively
influence
europe has tried to hang on to that idea
of being able to work with china rather
than against it for a little bit longer
at least in the united states i want to
play you another clip here secretary of
state anthony blinken from the united
states and he's made it very clear that
the u.s sees china's increasing
dominance as a threat and one that even
surpasses russia
even as president putin's war continues
we will remain focused on the most
serious long-term challenge to the
international order
and that's posed by the people's
republic of china
china is the only country with both the
intent to reshape the international
water
and increasingly
the economic
diplomatic military and technological
power to do it
beijing's vision would move us away from
the universal values that have sustained
so much of the world's progress
over the past 75 years
then decoupling from china is uh a
phrase that we've heard a lot decoupling
was a bit of a buzzword in general and
and regionalization localization uh all
things that were talked about an awful
lot at uh davao so we entering a more
fractured world
definitely and i would call it a
disentanglement and regrouping because
it's not just uh it's a two-way road
here china it's heavily reliant on so
many of its geopolitical
rivals uh so taiwan um
as far as uh products go it's aerospace
industry it's like 98
reliant on on foreign help as far as
that sector goes uh but also foreign
expertise so germany japan south korea
singapore um it's going to be
complicated and we're entering a very
complicated stage i think in in
globalization and it's going to take a
lot of like i said before behind the
scenes work and i saw
that as far as the oil sector went uh
when i was in davos with a lot of people
heading to the saudi arabia house
including israel
including
germany including all of these big
countries that are trying to fill the
gap because it takes time as we heard
from our guests um yeah they're playing
catch-ups somewhat as well they are and
it's an urgent situation because
germany's trying to weed itself off oil
by the end of the year and gas as well
at some stage yeah there's been a real
sort of swing that they've had to go
through in the past few months and and
maybe some of this was predictable
certainly the united states would tell
the germans yeah the germans that they
predicted some of the problems they're
currently having but speaking of the
united states that's the world's you
know biggest economy it's undoubtedly
going to play a major part in whatever
world emerges in the coming years so
let's hear from dw's financial
correspondent in new york jens quarter
there is a lot of talk in the united
states as well if we might be seeing the
beginning of the end of globalization at
least as we knew it in the past a couple
of
decades the term deglobalization might
be a bit misleading because what most
economists see is that we won't see at
the end of international trade but that
the united states for example is trying
to cut the dependence um on the supply
chain especially
from south east asia there are terms
like near shoring so for example that
you try to bring a production closer to
the united states for instance or
the head of the
treasury janet yellen she phrased it
recently with um
friendsharing so meaning that you try to
bring production to countries that are
friendly to you i mean that could for
example in the case of the united states
be
mexico or um other nations and then we
had see already some trend in the
fashion industry to bring some
production um closer to the united
states to middle america for example
countries um like guatemala or um
honduras and bringing some of the
production at least back um from
southeastern asia and we've seen it not
just what's happening with the war in
the ukraine with the supply chains from
china but also if you think back what
happened when the surest canal
was actually blocked so how vulnerable
those supply chains are and that's why
near shoring or french shoring might be
a trend for the future
jen's quarter in new york was
friendshiping was a new one for me there
uh anahita toms
we were hearing the point of view
from the united states there on what the
future looks like is europe on the same
page
i think that the us and the eu are once
again converging on global trade
questions we had
our own
trade wars as you recall
i would say that under president biden
the u.s is now again committed to
the partnerships with friends and allies
like germany like the european union
and we are also seeing again a
multilateral trade policy we're seeing
negotiations we see the trade and
technology council meetings in
paris
developing quite well where it's about
strengthening trade and and
labor dialogue as well as
focusing actually on common values like
um
labor issues like
human rights but also we're seeing that
the us and is is getting back on track
on um overarching common ambitions like
climate change issues so i would say um
that there is of course protection
there is of course
the bi-american
wording that that president biden still
uses and he will constantly defend
u.s jobs nevertheless i think that the
geopolitical tensions and also uh the
common values have brought the us more
closely again with europe and i think
that this is uh going to to to last
and pursuing i think it's definitely
going to be a values based
um
fracture we see around the world but
also a chance for many countries to
suddenly have a say and have and play
their part now um and not just be the us
and the eu
or china and and whoever else
but we saw during the pandemic heaps of
countries piling into vietnam and
producing their
investors at davos told me that vietnam
is now full so we're seeing this
overspelling into cambodia and cambodia
is trying to present itself as a
transparent nation that will be a great
business partner for producers around
the world okay man well we've heard a
lot from the united states and i
mentioned comparing them you know we
talk about the west we talk about the
united states we talk about europe a lot
of the time but let's hear from a
european leader on this i mean
so
if we ask the question is a world of
regionalization localization and
nationalization a better world well for
the last word on that let's hear from
the german chancellor olaf shorts who
gave the final keynote at the uh world
economic forum this time around
more economic resilience is the order of
the day in this multi-polar crisis-prone
world
and here too the answer must be
diversification for politics and
business alike
at the same time we must be careful that
the necessary diversification does not
become a pretext for isolation
tariff barriers and protectionism to put
it bluntly de-globalization is the wrong
track it will not work
the wrong track is that the message that
you were hearing a lot from davos that
deglobalization was right you'd expect
it from there but is there any converts
that that was basically the message i
was getting along with a greener
globalization okay ben for zulin thank
you so much for joining us on this dw
business special looking at decoupling
and de globalization i would like to
thank my guest sir ben fazoulen here in
the studio with me and anahita toms
thank you so much for joining us from
the international law firm baker
mckenzie uh right now if you've enjoyed
this video by the way do remember to hit
like and subscribe as we always say here
on youtube and uh also you should check
out our dw business beyond series it's
also on there for me and the team and
from down here it's a goodbye and thank
you very much until next time take care